so i'm going to talk about gamma the
lorentz factor which we have already
done a video about but there's enough to
say about it i thought we'd do a kind of
gamma reloaded video and then have
another go at it yeah i reloaded yeah i
like that
nice
gamma is a factor that comes up in
special relativity it's it's
kind of appears in a lot of equations in
special relativity and one of the places
it occurs in this thing is this thing
called time dilation you see something
going past you so something that's
traveling relative to you the clocks in
that reference frame seem to be going
slow relative to your reference frame so
that time you know the clocks tick more
slowly and everything goes more slowly
biological processes go more slowly
radioactive decay goes more slowly and
so on so really time really is slowed
down when something's moving relative to
you okay so in our last video about this
we talked about uh one of the proofs
that this actually occurs which is that
there are these particles called muons
created when high energy particles crash
into the top of the atmosphere and the
muons are then detected down on the
earth and the reason why this is a bit
of a surprise is because muons don't
live very long they have very short
decay times and actually if you just
figure it out you know even traveling at
the speed of light the fastest light
speed they could travel at the muons
don't actually have enough time to make
it to the earth so most of the muons
should have decayed before they get to
the earth but actually if you put a muon
detector on the earth you find plenty of
them are getting through and the reason
is is because these muons are traveling
at high speeds close to the speed of
light that means that as measured from
our reference frame their clocks are
going more slowly which means that they
don't decay so quickly and so they have
actually got time to get all the way
down to the earth without decaying as
mentioned in our reference frame
suddenly their lifetimes become maybe 10
or 100 times longer than they were and
the factor by which they become longer
is actually this factor this gamma
factor that we're talking about so as i
say there are lots of other phenomena
that are sort of associated with this
factor of gamma and one that we can get
at quite easily is by thinking about
what happens from the muon's point of
view right so from a muon's point of
view it comes into existence it's
suddenly born somewhere at the top of
the atmosphere and it sees the earth
rushing up to meet it
okay so it's just sitting there and sees
the earth coming towards it because
that's you know that's relativity that's
what it's all about and the question is
well in its own reference frame it's
just going to live as long as it usually
does right there's nothing special going
on as far as this new one's concerned
it's just sitting there stationary and
so actually you know if it looks as if
watch it's everything's you know times
are going at the normal kind of rate and
so it's going to live for the normal
lifetime that a muon's going to live for
and so in its reference frame if it had
the same distance to travel it wouldn't
live long enough you know the earth
rushing up towards it wouldn't it
wouldn't have there wouldn't be time for
the earth to travel at 50 or 100
kilometers from from where it was when
it was first created to smash into it
and so there's got to be some other
effect that's going on that from the
muons perspective actually allows it to
reach the earth because it does reach
the earth we can detect them on the
earth and so the muon has to also agree
that it reaches the earth and so this
other factor is this thing called
lorentz contraction that as well as time
being affected by motion distances are
affected by motion as well and so when
something's moving
along the line of sight in the direction
it's moving distances get squashed so
instead of having to travel 50
kilometers from being created down to
the earth it might only have to travel a
few hundred meters because in its
reference frame it sees that distance
greatly compressed and so all the
distances are squashed in that direction
so as far as it's concerned the earth's
atmosphere is only about 50 meters thick
and it only has to travel that 50 meters
so it actually has time to get all the
way from the top of the atmosphere to
the earth because even though it's
clock's going at the normal kind of
speed it sees all the distances squashed
remember it's actually only contracted
in the direction that the muon's moving
so actually everything gets really
distorted so your tree has a normal
width but it's suddenly a few
millimeters high maybe so actually yeah
no you things could look very very weird
from your perspective when you're
traveling close to the speed of light
because all these distances get
contracted there's a famous thought
experiment involving a train in a tunnel
the idea is you've got a train and
you've got a tunnel which is exactly the
same length as the train and so if
you're a train spotter who's standing
there beside the railway watching the
trains go by you see this train
approaching and because this train's
moving relative to you you see it
laurence contracted it's a bit shorter
than it should be and that means that as
it goes into the tunnel it disappears
completely in the tunnel it's because
it's shorter than the tunnel like the
tunnel's not moving relative to you
you're standing next to it so therefore
the tunnel is its normal length but
because this train is moving relative to
you it becomes a little bit shorter so
it disappears into the tunnel fine so it
actually is briefly kind of hidden at
both ends of the tunnel but now if we
think about somebody sitting on the
train's perspective somebody sitting on
the train they think they're stationary
you know the table there in front of
them they can drink their cup of coffee
when they put it down it just stays
there so they're in their reference
frame and everything's normal and
they're seeing the countryside rushing
by and so they see this tunnel
approaching them at high speed and of
course because they're seeing this
tunnel moving the tunnels should be
contracted
and so from their perspective they
should never completely disappear into
the tunnel because they see a tunnel
which is shorter than the train so
therefore the train never completely
disappears by the time the back end of
the trains disappeared into the tunnel
the front ends come out the other end
and that's all well and good and okay
maybe they just agree to differ about
whether the train is shorter than the
tunnel or not but unfortunately you can
then do another experiment which is you
can say okay so if this trainspotter
actually is you know has a rather a lot
of power and bizarrely someone has
installed two large guillotines one at
either end of the tunnel and at the
moment the train disappears into the
tunnel he pulls a lever which briefly
makes these guillotines come down and
then go back up again then from his
perspective that's fine because the
trains disappeared into the tunnel they
can do that without doing any damage
okay from the point of view of somebody
approaching the tunnel if this happens
it's not going to be such good news
because
from their perspective the train is
longer than the tunnel which means
either the front of the train gets
chopped off or the back of the train
gets chopped off or both okay and this
is something that everyone has to agree
on right because if you actually do the
experiment either you end up with a
smash train or you don't and ultimately
that's going to be something that
everyone has to agree about it's not
something that you can just say well
it's just a matter of perspective that's
all just relative right either the train
gets broken or it doesn't
so what happens so there is a resolution
to this paradox and the resolution to
this paradox turns out to be something
very fundamental in relativity and it's
called the relativity of simultaneity
which basically means which things which
are simultaneous in one reference frame
are not necessarily simultaneous in
another reference frame so in fact both
of these people agree that the train
doesn't get smashed but the reason why
they agree the train doesn't get smashed
is different right the guy who's pulling
the lever says well the train obviously
didn't get smashed because it was
shorter than the tunnel so that was fine
the guy in the train sees something
completely different in that what he
says is that actually what happened is
the train was approaching before it went
right through the tunnel the front
guillotine came down and went back up
again then after it pretty much passed
through the back guillotine came down
and back up again and so actually they
kind of missed the train as it went
through
and and so this is what both of them see
they both agree that actually the
train's fine but the reason is that
because the things which were
simultaneous in one reference frame the
guy was just standing next to the tunnel
said these things happen both at the
same time the guy who's in the train
said actually no one happened first then
the other
and so that's you know that's the
resolution to the paradox is that this
whole concept of simultaneity kind of
goes away in special relativity that
things which one person says both these
things happened at the same time
somebody else will say no actually that
one happened first and that one happened
second
because whether things happen at the
same time really depends on what
reference frame you're measuring them in
but what's the fact did the train
disappear in the tunnel or did it fall
out the ends what actually happened both
i think it just depends on who the rest
from frame you're in right in one
reference frame that's exactly what
happens um you know if you think about
it the train sticking out of both ends
of the tunnel relies on somebody's
simultaneous measurements right the
front was sticking out at the same time
that the back was sticking out
and because different people disagree
about simultaneity it's quite possible
for them to disagree about whether both
ends of the train is sticking out of the
tunnel at the same time
how does this go down when you teach
this to students the students love it i
have to say i mean one of the really
nice things is although we avoid all the
maths in these videos actually the math
you need to do this properly isn't very
hard the most difficult math you need to
do this properly is trigonometry and
just basically pythagoras theorem you
know the square on the hypotenuse is
equal to the sum of the squares on the
other two sides so the nice thing about
it is this is something which is
actually mathematically not that
difficult but which is conceptually
mind-blowing
and so it's actually one of the things
we teach the students quite early it's
in the first semester of the first year
here
just because it's something where you
can do the maths but actually end up
with a result that has you really
scratching your head and actually one of
the things i always warn the students
when we're starting to do this is that
usually
in physics what we tell them repeatedly
is if you get something that looks like
a stupid answer at the end you've
probably done something wrong so go back
check make sure you haven't messed up
this is one of those cases where if you
get something that looks like a stupid
answer at the end you've probably done
it right because the results that come
out especially relativity are so bizarre
that actually you do end up with these
apparent paradoxes all over the place